on Prime crime
a vicious murder of a child
ignites a search for a killer he just
asked me if I ever killed somebody the
victim wrote to her mother mom someone
is knocking on the door
[Music]
hey there everybody I'm Jesse Weber and
welcome to prime prime this is where we
break down the most high profile and
memorable True Crime cases a young girl
is found murdered but what she does
beforehand leads investigators to the
main suspect
[Music]
this chilling 9-1-1 phone call is from
August 10th 2017. it was placed in a
mobile home park out in Goodlettsville
Tennessee by Patricia Velazquez and her
daughter Jocelyn Ortega
[Applause]
[Music]
in listening to 9-1-1 tapes and you know
working with them in a number of
homicide cases during my time as a
prosecutor the pain of her mother sounds
the same and no matter what language you
hear it
that there's just a certain tone and
once you hear it it sits with you
foreign
[Music]
this began the investigation into the
death of 12-year-old Johanna Ortega
Johannes murder was one of the more
brutal cases that I've reviewed it
happened in a location that I think that
most 12 year olds
would feel safe and secure and that's
that's in their home when this child was
found she was found with a martial arts
belt
wrapped around her neck not once but
twice it was secured
in the back with a double knot her cause
of death ultimately is an asphyxial
death it's an asphyxial death by
strangulation whoever did this took
their time
when this child's earbuds were recovered
they were soaked in blood
diseased devices were in her ear perhaps
as she is being choked out
she didn't see this guy coming
and it only gets worse from there there
was a bit of disrobing that went went on
here anytime that you have the
appearance of of an event that might
have a sexual connotation you're always
going to do a sexual assault kid police
arrive on the scene and begin to Canvas
the area at one point Detective Chris
Bowden interviews johanna's neighbor Roy
Coons Jr
doing well you live here yeah you've
been here pretty much all day or I've
been in and out should be there for a
saw anything unusual strange nothing
stood out to you like I've never seen
that guy before no
Roy coons though is an ex-con who has
quite the history this is a man who has
been arrested 102 times
and his first arrest started when he was
19 years old 1999 he was convicted of
his third DUI guilty 2001 he was guilty
of aggravated assault with a deadly
weapon 2006 he's guilty of two counts of
aggravated assault with a deadly weapon
2010 guilty of aggravated burglary now
during this span of his first arrest
from 1991 to 2020. he also had 13
probation violations
this initial interaction with law
enforcement ends peacefully all right
man for you if I think anything or say
anything
I appreciate it but a short while later
Coons gets into a dispute with other
officers
anytime that you're on the scene of one
of those crimes and the police are there
and the police are there for a long time
you're gonna have your lucky loose
you're gonna have your people that kind
of stand around and watch but there was
something about Roy Coon that stood out
to the female officer she was the second
officer that arrived in the scene and
she went I feel like I need to go talk
to him
are you agitated because of the horrors
of what happened in your neighborhood
that's completely logical but at the
same token you do have to recognize that
law enforcement does need to do their
job and and do and conduct an
investigation why can't you just provide
the basic information needed so we can
eliminate you as a suspect and move on
to the next person
a little more than everybody else and
like I said I'm really sad most of the
time I don't come out because I don't
know how I am right and I get riled up
just keep my number I got the number and
it changed it if I say anything or hear
anything I promise oh you called me
before police leave they noticed Coons
throw a cigarette butt on the ground and
they quickly pick it up
if you found something that has been
discarded there will be some element of
you perhaps left behind and what finer
example of this than a cigarette butt
you're touching the exterior of the
cigarette but more importantly you're
essentially inoculating
and introducing your saliva
into the filter
uh you can find red blood cells in there
and of course red blood cells are a fine
fine Source uh for DNA
when we return Coons is interviewed
Again by police but is he the killer or
someone else the DNA evidence shows that
there are some other profiles that were
not identified
[Music]
[Music]
okay so when the internet we think that
he thinks of Patricia coming home
twelve-year-old Johanna Ortega is
discovered by her mother sister and
brother savagely murdered in their home
in Tennessee There's also evidence of
attempted sexual assault investigators
are piecing together not only how this
happened but who could have done it
police take an interest in Roy Coons Jr
and ex-con in neighbor to Ortega they
interview him outside of his trailer
home days after the murder
I mean I I really don't know him that
much
you know what they had going on or they
could go into the house and she's you
know surprised him or but I mean even me
and still that wouldn't make no sense if
I turned a burglary into a murder I
guess it's one of those things you just
have to do to put yourself in that
situation to find out they went there to
question him because he was somebody of
interest that one of the officers
noticed on the scene were you um
all that they leading up through five
left
um
and then we came back out
I'd say maybe
35-40 minutes there there's that
building Rapport right so kind of
breaking the guard down getting someone
to be more relaxed and at ease so then
when that person feels at ease they may
slip yes
[Music]
remind me
when I went down here and asked her
about the lawnmower and she died in the
longhorn
and then a couple times prior to that is
there any reason that we could ever
possibly find your DNA
on her
I would not shake their hand and stuff
like that
that exchange would be critical for a
very important reason Roy's DNA was
found in three locations it was found on
the back of a windowsill on a shirt and
on a sock Rory's DNA wasn't found on uh
the yellow karate belt that she was
strangled with a tissue a pillow a
mattress a bed rail her bra her shirt a
Cheetos wrapper the bed spread
um and her left breast
but where a ystr match where it could be
him or a paternal linkage to him was
found on a facial swab of hers it was
found on her right buttocks and her left
arm
DNA aside none of the prints at the
crime scene matched Coons it's very
difficult many Toms to find a latent
print or we don't have prints on the
ends of our fingers uh these are easily
obliterated you know you got to keep in
mind and this is quite fascinating the
day after the homicide
Coons was actually walking down the road
and there was a police officer that was
there one of the things that the police
officer noticed is that Coons had latex
gloves hanging out of his pocket during
that interaction police ask Coons about
potential suspects
[Music]
and one of them was in a truck of a big
custom truck or something and came up
this way
and every time he comes up down through
there he almost stops real slow which is
interesting considering what else was
discovered at the crime scene there were
other profiles of other men's DNA that
were found on that scene in that room
and on her body
coming up Johanna does something right
before she's killed that leads law
enforcement to their primary suspect you
begin to think about the text message
that Johanna sent out to her mother
earlier in the day it almost denotes
this idea of fear
[Music]
me her mom
you know she was she was the sweetest
thing too
in August 2017 law enforcement's
investigating the murder and attempted
rape of 12-year-old Johanna Ortega at
one point police interview johanna's
neighbor Roy Coons Jr who actually did
work for Johanna and her family
Coon says he didn't kill Johanna
strangely though DNA evidence from
certain parts of the crime scene link
back to Coons
Coons has asked a provocative question
happens
I was I was pretty much make sure that
they can do whatever my chat with you
you know like I was 79 yesterday was
Joe's system a while says
there's only one problem with that
statement he had intimate knowledge of
the events that had not been released to
the public
he talked about things like sexual
assault
strangulation first off he was hanging
around and now he has intimate knowledge
of a scene something that no one else
has had eyes on because I have been on
so many of these scenes in apartment
complexes and trailer parks and I used
to work on Dickerson Road and those it's
filled with apartment complexes and
trailer parks and when you get on a
stand like that I know that the police
say it wasn't out there but people are
talking I do believe it's possible that
it could have been overheard in the game
of telephone got played that oh she was
she was strangled and raped
but there's something else right before
Johanna was killed as she was Home Alone
nursing an injured ankle she sent a
series of text messages to her mother
these final words from Johanna would
help police in a major way
4 15 the victim wrote to her mother mom
someone is knocking on the door
and then at 419 the victim wrote back to
her mother
I think it was the man who cuts the yard
and at that point I knew that was was
very important because I was at the
crime scene and I knew that one of the
suspects was the the caretaker of the
lawn it wasn't for the grandson I don't
think I would have ever met him the text
message is a huge component it puts him
there it puts him in contact with her
right around the time that she was
murdered that gives you chills when you
begin to think of it looking for a
perpetrator that is predatory in nature
who would have the opportunity to
conduct this observation to see that
this child is at home by themselves and
to understand the environment the scene
if you will and all of that comes
together in kind of this horrible
horrible storm
in September 2017 Roy Coons Jr is
arrested and ultimately charged with the
murder and attempted rape of Johanna
Ortega yet as
strong enough for a jury to convict I
would have liked to have seen them
narrow it down a little bit more and had
a little bit more with the DNA than than
shutting it down in six weeks and going
this is definitely it
[Music]
what do you think the best way is
delicious
technology
I mean very much everybody around here
that they who knows people at home or
what nothing Source but it's left up to
the technology California
[Music]
in August 2017 12 year old Johanna
Ortega is found by her mother sister and
brother murdered and there's even
evidence of attempted sexual assault a
month later the family's neighbor Roy
Coons Jr is arrested and charged in
connection with johanna's death in July
2019 Coons went on trial for multiple
charges including first-degree murder
the prosecution laid out their case you
have the DNA that shows he was in
contact with her around the time that
she was murdered DNA wise TR profile
on the right cheek
on the right buttocks
and it was the exact same wise TR
profile
is Roy Coons Jr you'll look at his
statements you'll look at his knowing
certain facts about the crime that only
law enforcement and the person
committing the crime would have known he
knows that Joanna has been strangled
that information was not public at the
time the defendant knew it the text
message the basically words from Beyond
the grade that came from Johannes
4 19 PM she identifies the demand who is
knocking on the door of her trailer that
day was the man who cuts the lawn all
the proof you've heard has shown that
Roy Coons was the man who cut their lawn
in that trailer you put all of that
together
and that is what shows guilt however
this is not so simple as it seems
[Applause]
did not kill
did not attempt to rape and he did not
burglarize Johanna Ortega's hold on
you're not going to hear from a single
eyewitness that Mr Coombs went in that
mobile home on that day
[Music]
you're not going to see any video
footage from security cameras showing
that he did that
you're not going to hear from any
witnesses that he had an even motive or
an attempted to do anything to this
family in the past DNA that was
recovered in this case belonging to Mr
Coons was a matter of a few cells no
semen no blood no other identifiable
bodily fluid the biggest struggles for
the prosecution in this case has to do
with the fact that there's no real
direct evidence the other part that the
state's not wanting to talk about is the
fact that we have three other known hits
in CODIS to people's DNA that were in
that trailer one of the people that they
identified as having DNA there in the
scene in her body is a person who was on
probation or had been on probation and
they talked to his mom and they talked
to the probation officer nobody knew
where he had been they've ruled out a
couple other people but also there's
people they didn't rule out yeah before
the trial concluded the prosecution
presented another piece of evidence for
the jury to consider they allege that
after Johanna was killed Coons went to
live in a homeless encampment and while
there he made a startling admission he
just asked me if I ever killed somebody
I didn't ask him if he ever did but he
told me but he he has he didn't tell me
who he was or how long he was but he
said he did but and this is his what
that sticks with you that's what he said
I was so freaked out I I never get
scared many people will make comments
about these events without stating this
the specifics of the event he's got this
this burden this this thing that gnaws
at him he's sleeping in a wooded area
not too far away from a victim and I
think that that tells you a lot
with a jury by the defendant Ronald
Donald Coons Jr
and count one
guilty a second degree murder
count two felony murders guilty count
four
guilty of attempted regular child
five guilty of aggravated criminal I am
not surprised that the jury found him
guilty of second-degree murder as
opposed to first degree murder so first
degree murderers suggest premeditation
it means that he planned to commit this
crime to me it sounds like the jury
looked at all this evidence and felt
like it was a crime of opportunity that
that he was in the area happened to see
that Johanna was alone or figure out
that she was alone and took advantage in
that moment nonetheless Coons was
sentenced to life in prison plus an
additional 25 years
this was
a horrible day is seared into their
memory and I just can't even imagine the
pain that this family is going through
and will continue to go through because
we all know that a guilty verdict while
that may be the end of the case is not
the end of the trauma and The Grieving
journey of the those that are left
behind
when looking back at this case the DNA
evidence the police tapes the words of
the defendant it all led to his
conviction but you have to think that
johanna's text or her mom really helped
seal Coon's fate and in a way this 12
year old girl was able to catch her own
killer as always thanks for joining us
here on Prime crime and until next time
stay safe
[Music]
[Music]